[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to the 2022
ceremony for the access city awards they
were created by the european commission
to reward cities that have prioritized
improving accessibility for people with
disabilities and as a consequence
opening up to embrace the diverse needs
of their population
this matters because 70 percent of
europeans live in cities and towns these
are spaces where we live
work travel rest and play
making them disability inclusive and
accessible benefits both the 87 million
europeans living with a disability and
the growing proportion of older cities
the access city award recognizes the
willingness ability and efforts made by
cities to improve accessibility
the award is an opportunity to showcase
how a city can transform the experiences
of the people living there and it
becomes a beacon of good practice that
other cities can aspire to
today we will honor three exceptional
cities the winning city receives a
golden trophy and a cash prize of 150
000 euros a silver trophy is accompanied
by a 120 000 euro award and the bronze
trophy brings with it an envelope of 80
000 euros
to tell us more here is the european
commissioner for equality mrs helena
dally
good afternoon
let's say that you want to take a bus
but you cannot board it
that you want to go to a concert but you
cannot buy the ticket let alone get to
the venue and enjoy it
or that you take your child to the
playground but your child is unable to
play with the other children as nothing
is accessible
how would you feel about your city
i know how i would feel
accessibility is an enabler of rights
autonomy and equality or said
differently of happiness and freedom
this is why i value the access city
award
today we will be celebrating cities that
have made remarkable efforts to become
more accessible so that everyone can
truly enjoy what these cities have to
offer
for this 12th edition of the access city
award we received 40 applications from
across europe
to all applicants i want to say
thank you for your hard work
to build a city without barriers
six candidates were shortlisted for the
award
in alphabetical order they are
barcelona in spain
helsinki finland
leuven in belgium
luxembourg city in luxembourg palmer in
spain and porto in part in portugal
to me they are all winners and they will
all receive a prize today but only one
can take first place
we are looking for a city that is making
accessibility a priority
a city that is in constant dialogue with
persons with disabilities
a city that shows
genuine commitment
these qualities are exemplified by last
year's winner john shopping in sweden
today they will hand over the title to
another city
but first let me give the floor to the
mayor of john shopping
thank you and good afternoon
it's an honor to be here today and
represent john shipping municipality the
city that won the access city award 2021
an award that has given us the
opportunity to share our work with other
cities in europe and other parts of the
world
as well as to be inspired to further
development around accessibility in our
city
for many years there has been an
organized collaboration between the
municipality and representatives of the
disability rights federation and
pensioners organizations
thanks to this collaboration the
municipality has gained a lot of
knowledge about accessibility issues and
new ways to use it when we plan our city
the disability rights federation is
contributing with their knowledge and
experience in policy documents and in
procurements as well as when we plan the
design of some public spaces for example
parks
footpaths adapted playgrounds and
pedestrian crossings
working with accessibility in urban
planning makes the city more attractive
to all our citizens and visitors
in addition it also means benefits for
the business community such as shops
restaurants and more that can increase
their customer base thanks to better
accessibility
an accessible city is a living city
we have many challenges ahead of us
among other things we need to intensify
the work with digital accessibility
more and more of the public
communication and debate take place on
digital platforms
we need to ensure that everyone has the
opportunity to engage and use the
digital tools so no one feels
excluded
accessibility is ultimately about
democracy
to create a society where everyone is
included and can participate on equal
terms
this is how we build an inclusive city
together with our citizens for a better
europe
thank you
thank you
let's look again at how young shopping
won their award in 2021
graphics showing images of young
shopping
access city award 2022 young shopping
2021 winner aerial views of young
shopping city johann stewart from young
shopping disability rights federation
goes into his office
we see him working at his desk in a
wheelchair
multiplexer then
[Music]
shopping disability rights federation
sits at her computer using a braille
keyboard i mean history barrier this
year for
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
enters the building and shakes hands
with johan
hey
[Music]
[Music]
paulina is at the museum using a qr code
to listen to information
settings
[Music]
johan and his son are playing together
in an accessible playground
so then
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and
[Music]
um
the entrance the furniture the shelves
the entrance level and the different
floors
[Music]
but it is also about how someone with
disabilities can access the information
that the council
shares on its website or various
platforms
and there is absolutely more that can be
done to create a democratic society
where everyone is involved checking the
accessibility of stores in the city
we have an assignment to perform an
entry of 100 different stores and
traders
that you know whether you will even be
able to enter a visit
i think in our municipality we received
a very nice prize which we are
incredibly happy and proud of
but it is also an obligation
we must demonstrate
and keep on showing the improvements
that can be done to an accessible
viewing platform he then meets paulina
on an accessible path in the nature
reserve and borders
both the council and the disciplinary
rights federation uh have been
recognized it's been great for them to
win this prize the best thing about
winning the access city award is that we
feel we are on the right track on the
road with a friend ec dot europa dot eu
forward slash social forward slash
access city award
[Music]
eu access city
congratulations again to young shopping
now turning to 2022 let's take a look at
the cities that are shortlisted for
prizes this year
access city award 2022
for the last 11 years the eu has
recognized cities that are making
efforts to improve accessibility and
offer better access to city life for
persons with disabilities and older
people
every year cities are motivated by the
success of the previous winners to enter
the access city award
this year we have reached the landmark
of the 12th edition of the award
over a dozen years there have been 704
applicants and 78 prize-winning cities
access city award 2022
40 applications were received for the
access city award 2022 and six prizes
will be awarded one overall winner two
runners-up and three winners in special
mention categories
to celebrate the european year of real
there is one special mention category on
improving the accessibility of train
stations this year the six shortlisted
cities in alphabetical order are
barcelona spain helsinki finland
leuven belgium luxembourg city
luxembourg
palmer spain and porto portugal
the six winners of the access city award
2022 will join their predecessors in
becoming symbols of commitment
innovation and progress towards creating
genuinely accessible cities and serve as
inspiration to others across the eu and
beyond good luck to all
[Music]
yes indeed good luck to our six cities
that were shortlisted
and now let's get started with the first
award
from the golden age of steam to the
modern age of high-speed rail networks
trains are the connectors of our cities
across the continent they transport us
to workplaces to homes to family to
holidays and if
you can find platform nine and three
quarters they could take you to magical
places with this award we recognize
cities that have redesigned the physical
space of the train stations to be more
accessible the award is introduced by ms
adina vallianne the european
commissioner for transport
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen it
is an honor to join you virtually for
today's access city awards ceremony
this year's edition takes place during
the european year of rail as one of the
greenest and safest modes of transport
we certainly want to see more people
using rail whether to travel across
europe to go to work or visit family and
friends everyone should be able to take
the train and with ease
ensuring that everyone can travel safely
and comfortably across the union has
been on our agenda for many years that
is why we have in the eu
technical specifications for
interoperability for persons with
reduced mobility
they set technical requirements on
assistance when boarding trains on
ticketing and information systems on
obstacle-free routes in stations on
parking facilities and more
as part of our revision of the rail
passenger rights regulation we reduce
the pre-notification period for those
needing assistance from 48 to 24 hours
this should further increase the
attractiveness of traveling by train for
such persons
looking into a broader context i am
pleased that the european accessibility
act will also apply to rail transport
this is an important step forward we are
doing our bit
to make rail more attractive for all and
many cities are doing the same
because every journey starts with a
station these places need to be inviting
accessible and easy to navigate for all
of us
today pay tribute to a city that has
made impressive changes to its rail
system
including its metro network
to make it accessible for people with
disabilities or reduced mobility
a city that takes steps to make mobility
seamless so that all of its citizens can
enjoy city life to the full
the winner of the special mention for
making train stations more accessible
during the european year of rail
is
porto
congratulations
ricardo
thank you
i think that you are listening now
uh so thank you uh
for this award
so i have here a little speech so that
[Music]
i will make it
so dear madame serves dear members of
the jury thank you all
this recognition make us extremely happy
and proud in the city of porto
it is indeed with great satisfaction
that we see recognize all the effort and
commitment of the municipality to endow
porto with the best accessibility
conditions a city we want to be from
everyone and to everyone
accessibility is an issue that is on the
agenda demanding cities to adapt and
reinvent themselves
to meet the needs of their resident
population
or those who study work or just visit
the cities in our case
this is particularly challenging gold
as it
forces to bypass the natural and
morphological conditions of the ancient
city of portugal
those who have visitors knows that the
winding and steep streets of the
historical center as well as the
different elevations
make pedestrian dislocation very
difficult
especially
for senior citizens and people
with reduced mobility
the truth is that as they invicta city
that we are
we never surrender and turn our
adversities into opportunities
therefore those who visit us regularly
notice the transformation the city
is undergoing
we have sought to implement innovative
solutions as this is the
on the railway
together with our stakeholders to
mitigate difficulties and correct the
symmetries
to ensure that everyone without
exception has full access everywhere and
can enjoy the city that's why we put
together a city economic development
strategy and a social cohesion strategy
that without neglecting the importance
of access to culture employment support
as well as simplifying access to public
services
knowing that all these dimensions
contribute to the population's quality
of life especially the most vulnerable
groups
and this is what exactly the city is
doing in terms of the organization of
the territory
through the municipal master plan and in
the social development strategy the
social development plan
in recent years we have been strongly
investing in each of these areas in the
expansion and improvement of the public
transportation network and soft modes
at affordable prices rehabilitating and
building new equipment restoring public
space but also at the same time
creating integration programs in the
labor market promoting active aging and
social cohesion in fact
for over a decade porto has been
integrating several national and
international projects
focusing on social development
aligning its strategy and adopting best
practices
it is in this sense that we have been
working to offer a city with high
quality of life for those who live work
or study here
providing the best experience for those
who visited and attractive conditions
for those who invest in it
but above all we want to guarantee a
more equitable and inclusive
quality of life in the city
fortunately this has been recognized and
for instance monaco magazine elected
porto as the best small city in the
world to live in 2021
so this recognition bring us a new
encouragement to our journey
as it reinforces that we are trailing
the way that will make porto an even
friendly city for everybody thank you
very much for the recognition
thank you very much ricardo warm
congratulations to you and all of your
team
now let's find out more about the
changes that porto made to their train
stations
access city award 2022
special mentioned for improving
accessibility of train stations to
celebrate the european year of real
porto portugal 231
962 inhabitants
porto the second largest city in
portugal with its renowned historic
center has worked hard in recent years
to make its real system more accessible
for everyone
in particular the city has shown a
strong commitment to improving its two
main train stations sabent and campagna
porto has specifically targeted persons
with disabilities with several
improvements which bring their train
stations in line with their national
legislation accessible parking in close
proximity to both stations has been
created as well as tactile floors and
adapted public sanitary facilities a
kiss and ride system has been
established and all pavements adjacent
to the stations have lowered curbs in
places to support accessibility
sabent is now remarkably accessible with
entrances to the station accessible
counters at the ticket office and
accessible platforms
campania has also made its halls ticket
offices and platforms accessible the
station also boasts an underpass for
pedestrians which spans several
platforms with lift access
portal has also made improvements to its
metro system with increasingly
accessible vehicles and stations as well
as audible warnings and adapted
equipment throughout
thanks to these efforts and in order to
highlight its incredible work during
this european year of reel porto wins a
special mention for improving the
accessibility of its train stations
[Music]
congratulations again to porto for their
fabulous work on their rail
accessibility
now let's move to the next category
the pandemic has brought home to us all
just how important green space is to our
mental well-being
being able to see and touch nature has
been a vital lifeline when physical
contact between people carried such a
deadly risk
natural areas and biodiversity are a
huge asset and cities have woken up to
the opportunity to promote new tourism
opportunities by making their natural
spaces accessible to the biggest number
of people
to introduce the next award here is mr
juanes varga castanes the president of
the european disability forum
distinguished guests and participants
it is very promising to see
that despite the strain
on the epidemic on our societies and
economies cities around europe continue
to advance
accessibility for persons with
disabilities
and share their experience
through another very successful edition
of the access city award
in accessibility of the built
environment
remains
a great barrier
for millions of persons with
disabilities to participate
in society and to live independently in
their communities
it is for this reason
that today's special mention
on accessibility
of the physical environment
is of great importance to me and i am
very honored to announce the winner but
before
i reveal
which city has won this year's special
mention
i would like
to take this opportunity
to emphasize that we have a huge
opportunity to advance accessibility
of the
built environment in europe
through the european accessibility act
as the national governments are
transposing the act
i urge them
to transpose the build environment
accessibility requirements of the act
to make sure
persons with disabilities
can participate fully
and equally
in their communities and enjoy
freedom of movement and mobility
i also urge
public authorities architects building
companies and urban planners
to make good use
of the european standard
on
accessibility of the build environment
the city
that has
them deserved
the special
mention for the physical environment
including natural areas for inclusive
tourism has demonstrated a sustainable
and strategic approach
to advancing accessibility
for its residents
and visitors alike
it has done this
through continuous investments in
developing accessibility of public
spaces like
parks
playgrounds
public square beaches as well as
services
by listening to
and closely involving
its community members to achieve
progress
dear participants
of the access city awards
i am very pleased to announce
the winner of this
year's special mention
for the physical environment including
natural
areas
to inclusive
tourism
and the winner
is
palma
spain
congratulations
palma
si hariteria
palma
hello and thank you
well we kind of guessed it
when you describe the countryside and
the environment we're in a privileged
area in
mallorca where the capital of the
balearics and
our environment and our
natural park are
incomparable
so dear authorities of the european
committees representatives of the jury
and participants of the ceremony hello
um we haven't eaten yet in palma firstly
on behalf of kali
of the mayor mr
hoisina and on my behalf and
accessibility services i'd like to thank
you for the recognition that the that
palma has received for its continual
transformation into an area that is
accessible to all we work with the
entities of the sector on a daily basis
in our
committee
on accessibility there's a constant
dialogue and we work on
the areas of parks
gardens
and
playgrounds as well
and
we want everything to be accessible to
everything but another thing is
everybody is
is another thing is universal access
uh so that everybody can enjoy uh every
services
and installations beyond our disability
mine and other people's disability as
well we have made great strides in
making different types of infrastructure
accessible and
we
uh have done so from the very stage of
design
and
[Music]
the
uh accessible design is the light motif
and everything we design we design and
conceive for everybody we are we want a
city for everybody
uh from
a perspective of empathy and
inclusion we don't want anyone limited
in any way
in their mobility and their capacity to
interact socially and personal autonomy
we have a dynamic open welcoming
inclusive and friendly city
for
those who live in palma and for those
who visit us i hope that you will come
and visit us shortly there's still a lot
to be done and we are working on that
the renovation of assistance-based
infrastructure
and municipal
services are taking place
under
municipal
specialized teams
and
we
want uh every community to have full
guarantee of inclusion so thank you very
much
for your recognition of the work that
we're going to do and that we're going
to be doing in the next few years
this really puts wind in our sails we're
happy to be working in that direct
direction
and we are happy to be included among
this uh select a group of cities thank
you very much for the recognition and as
i said before
open arms we hope to welcome you
we're here all year
sometimes it's a bit
rainy
but the climate is over well
overall better than uh cities uh more in
the north so you're welcome thank you to
everybody and have a lovely afternoon
actions again and thank you
let's find out more why palmer is being
recognized
access city award 2022
special mention for the physical
environment including natural areas for
inclusive tourism palma spain 416 065
inhabitants
palma on the island of majorca is one of
europe's leading tourist destinations
this however presents a challenge for
the city as it must accommodate both
locals and tourists wishing to access
its many public spaces
recognizing this issue palmer has made
it a clear priority to make its outdoor
areas such as beaches and parks more
accessible for persons with disabilities
and older people in order to accommodate
everyone
there are now six assisted bathing spots
across the city's five accessible
beaches
palmer has also created a park garden
and public square improvement plan which
aims to improve 57 open spaces across
the city by including for example
inclusive playgrounds and universally
designed furniture
working closely with a local
organization the palma 365 foundation
five touristic routes have been created
which include cultural leisure and
commercial sites
and accessible brochure is available
online which specifies the routes
buildings and public transport that are
physically auditory and visually
accessible each route starts in one of
the six tourism information offices
there are also nine citizens assistance
offices equipped with hearing loops for
visitors with hearing impairments and
visual accessibility kits for visitors
with visual impairments
as a result of this broad approach
palmer wins a special mention for its
inclusive approach to improving the
accessibility of its physical
environment
[Music]
congratulations again to beautiful
palmer for winning that award
let's now turn to the next award
over the past two years the pandemic
triggered an enormous shift to digital
technologies and tools
ninety percent of the world's workplaces
and education environments were
disrupted as we had to adapt to the
reality of doing everything online
working learning socializing and
shopping went digital
limited accessibility of those digital
solutions
is a huge barrier for the many europeans
with disabilities but it is possible to
use technology to improve and widen
accessibility
this next award recognizes this and is
introduced by jesus hernandez galen who
chaired the 2022 access city awards
jesus
over to you
thank you very much good afternoon to
everybody my name is
i have the honor to be the member of
jury of access city awards since the
beginning
in this edition i take the role of a
chairperson and
to me it has been an hour and i'm very
proud to be part of this
award i would like to remark the quality
of the candidates
here we can see the application more
quality and stronger commitment with
accessibility for that i am sure these
awards are promoting accessibility
all around europe
so i congratulate your european
commission for these
awards and i would like to announce the
winner for a special mention for many
streaming of accessibility including
in the digital area
to
logan belgium
the jury members remarked that logan
stood out for this
main streaming approach and for looking
at accessibility from
different angles and website and the
apps developed by the city have a very
good accessibility so congratulations
thank you good afternoon everyone
as the deputy mayor for equal
opportunities of living i'm honored to
be one of the finalists for the access
city award
we believe that we've made some crucial
steps with regard to accessibility in
recent years and i'm very glad that the
jury is of the same opinion
to us creating an accessible public
space means removing barriers for pub
for people with disabilities as much as
possible
it doesn't mean that
it doesn't only involve adjustments to
the infrastructure but also organize
organizing accessible events and
providing accessible services for
example low stimulus days at fairs and
this year's open monument day which was
dedicated to inclusive heritage
moreover everyone benefits from an
accessible public space including
children and people with
push chairs or relators for example
our work with regard to accessibility
has a strong human rights base as
accessibility is a fundamental human
right every human has the right to fully
participate in society and by preference
in the most autonomous way possible
the fact that we applicated for the
award does not mean that the work in
leuven is finished we are well aware
that there is still work to be done in
various areas
in our candidacy we've listed a lot of
plans for example we will rework the
advice of the accessibility advisory
board into an accessibility standard
we see our candidacy as a stimulus to
continue to work hard in the years to
come to achieve an accessible leuven
the strength of accessibility in level
lies in the cooperation with the
accessibility advisory council the
council consists of more than 15 active
members who provide their insights on
autism or motor visual auditory and
intellectual disabilities on a monthly
basis because of the diversity of
disabilities represented in the advisory
board a fair solution is automatically
sought that works for everyone
also for people without
disabilities this leads to concrete
advice
includes consultations with the
city services involved architects
architects and event organizers
among others
it is the full credit of the
accessibility advisory council to
to involve architects urban planners
event organizers to make
extra efforts to achieve our common goal
the advisory board challenges their
creativity and expertise and encourages
them to find real solutions for real
people who have the very normal need and
desire to participate in society to live
to learn to work to move to enjoy to
love to educate children in our city
leuven
congratulations to the winner i'm very
curious and to the other finalists i do
hope that we will continue to learn from
each other
a big thank you to everyone who has
contributed to our candidacy and who has
dedicated themselves to accessibility in
leuven in recent years
i would like to thank in particular the
current and previous members of the
accessibility advisory council the
president sami hills in particular and
the city services who prepared our
candidacy thank you
congratulations again lise well done
now let's see how lervan prioritized
digital accessibility
[Music]
access city award 2022 special mention
for mainstreaming accessibility
including in the digital area leuven
belgium
100 500 inhabitants
leuven a historical city in belgium
faces the challenge of combining its
unique character with the needs of a
modern accessible city
to tackle this the city has involved
citizens institutions organizations and
companies in its policies to improve
accessibility in an innovative way
at a policy level levin takes into
consideration the diversity of
disabilities including the challenges
faced by older people and barriers faced
by parents with prams
when implanting policy levin imposes an
accessibility level on itself that is
higher than what is legally required
the city's accessibility advisory board
established in 2008 including architects
service providers and event organizers
plays a key role and provides a
practical approach to accessibility
for example
in the construction of buildings leuven
considers door widths gradients and
turning circles at an early stage it
also considers the acoustics and colors
of the finished building
the city has also undertaken to survey
all its footpaths including in parks and
forest areas to tackle those more
difficult paths to access
leuven further focuses on the
accessibility of information both online
and written
in addition to its already accessible
information boards and websites the city
is currently consulting with the
university of leuven to make information
about their public spaces available
online
acknowledging that there is still work
to do to improve accessibility the city
has created an online notification
center alerting users to potential
accessibility problems at certain public
spaces
for mainstreaming accessibility with
innovative and digital solutions
leuven wins a special mention
[Music]
congratulations again to leuven for that
well-deserved prize
now we've come to the part of the
ceremony where we find out which city
won the top awards for their efforts to
increase accessibility for persons with
disability the access city award
recognizes the willingness the ability
and efforts made by cities to improve
accessibility and it's an opportunity to
showcase just how a city can transform
the experiences of the people living
there it becomes a beacon of good
practice that other cities can aspire to
right now we're going to honor the three
exceptional cities the winning city gets
a golden trophy and a reprise of 150 000
euros a silver trophy is accompanied by
120 000 euros and the bronze trophy
brings an envelope of 80 000 euros
the access city third prize will be
presented by katarina yankovic knesevich
the director for social rights and
inclusion at dg employment
katarina
thank you very much thompson
and congratulations to all three cities
having won a special mention
you are really improving the quality of
life of your citizens you are building
an inclusive society that starts with
ensuring ensuring that everybody
regardless of age mobility or disability
has equal access to all the resources
and diversity cities had to have to
offer
let us now start with the top three of
this year's competition
i can feel the tension rising as i'm
about to announce the third place
winning city
this city
has proved its commitment to
accessibility
let me tell you it has previously won a
prize in the access city award
competition
it is now rewarded for its strong
commitment to accessibility and for its
continuous improvements
indeed
this city has adopted an enduring
approach towards universal design
it has a strong accessibility plan that
started with a detailed analysis of the
accessibility of its public spaces
facilities and services
based on that the city started to
implement changes and is continuing to
monitor the situation
the third place winner
of the axis city of war 2021
is
the city of barcelona congratulations
barcelona
hello
hello thank you very much thank you very
much good afternoon from from barcelona
we are here at this ceremony because the
convention of rights for people with
disabilities
a city that we who live in the city is
considered to be absolutely essential
the convention recognize the importance
of accessibility to the physical social
economic and cultural environment this
is the main framework for action that we
share
congratulations to helsinki loven
luxembourg palmer and porto which have
we we have been shortlisted for the 2022
access city hours we have to work
together
we have to cooperate because in effect
universal accessibility is not just for
today population with disabilities who
live in cities accessibility stands for
the quality of life of the vast majority
of population
barcelona has a strong commitment with
accessibility policies and has developed
several initiatives to implement the
convention of rights of people with
disabilities
we can see
its commitment in terms of what does the
city have with and which we are the
challenge face in accessibility arena
during the past year
the past years in barcelona have made an
effort in terms of accessibility
without being exhaustive we are going to
highlight some of our milestones
for example the first one we have
developed accessibility policies in
transport service
in the field of transport
we have got the 92 percent of
accessibility of accessible
underground stations
or
second we have several accessibility
service and projects for persons with
disability for example the bathing
support system in four beach
over and we have got to work for four
and or five thousand users and in here
we have uh
accessibility lawyer accessibility
master plan
and the first we have a direct
participation and engagement no we we
work cross-cutting methodology to
mainstream accessibility inclusion
in all city council policies
now
that we are in this ceremony and we are
already
uh an international benchmark we need to
share
our action for accessibility accessible
public spaces transparent service we are
not doing this alone many things to all
the persons with disabilities
who have pushed
for a more accessible barcelona and to
all
non-governmental organizations and
professionals who have made possible
that our cities have increased in
accessibility level we need them to
enter a new level thank you very much
and thank you for the hour
thank you
and congratulations again barcelona for
your well-deserved second time winning a
prize in the access city awards
now let's move up to the next category
and the access city's second prize will
be announced by euster quarter the
director general for employment social
affairs and inclusion
eusta please tell us
who's won the second prize
thank you very much
tasman it's good to see you thompson
it's good to see you again
i'm very happy to be here um
good afternoon
first of all i would obviously like to
congratulate barcelona for winning the
third prize very well done
we also applaud all of the cities that
have received a special mansion here
today
it's extremely encouraging to see that
so many cities across europe are going
above and beyond to make life easier for
persons with disabilities
having an accessible city
is truly an enabler of rights
autonomy and equality for persons with
disabilities
removing these barriers
is a cornerstone of our efforts to
create a union of equality
but
it's also important for tourists with
suitcases
for parents with prams
and for older people
and in the end for all of us
we are honored to award the second prize
to a city that has gone above and beyond
to remove barriers of all kinds this
year
making public spaces buildings services
and transport safe and accessible for
all
so that everyone can enjoy city life
we see that the second place winner has
a long-standing commitment to
accessibility
the winner of the second place
at the access city award 2022 is
let me now open the envelope
helsinki
congratulations
thank you
oh my god
it feels great
uh it feels like um
that one can be really proud
and humble at the same time because one
can still uh reach for uh higher goals
here in helsinki we are really honored
to be recognized uh
by the second place and this truly also
encourages us to work further uh within
the accessibility of this city
i want to share with you
a few
[Music]
few things that we consider important
and things with which we have been
working
lately
but i will just start with the
vision or the guidelines how we are
building the city
helsinki for all
helsinki is a city in which everyone can
move and live with ease
streets and green areas buildings and
public transport solutions are easy to
use
and blend seamlessly together
public services are available to
everyone
and i think these sentences
make the picture that we really want to
do it for everyone
to disabled people to elderly people to
people with
long-term sicknesses
but also as it was mentioned to those
who use
uh relator or those who
uh had the child uh in a stroller
i think that the strengths of our work
is that we have been working with
accessibility for a long time and one
can say that it is it is incorporated in
the strategies objectives
in the city divisions policies and in
spare head projects
we have wanted to be systematic and
those examples
and examples of this include that the
accessibility guidelines produced by the
city ensure the accessibility
we have target levels for the
accessibility of public spaces or
buildings
there is a service map for providing
information on accessibility
the accessibility representative
is involved
in the preparation
of projects in a very early phase
already
people with disabilities are able to
discuss with architects and other
planners who are designing the buildings
beforehand and that is something i
consider crucial
the city of helsinki council on
disability
also works hard works systematically
and
has granted its annual accolade
to a party or act that promotes equal
participation among local residents with
disabilities and the easy access for
services
we're building a new light rail line
and there's a new tram car
and disability council and that has been
part of designing that
i also want to mention the uh
era that we have been living with the
pandemic and the importance of natural
areas that was already mentioned uh in
the ceremony and i myself really proud
that just before the pandemic hit us
actually we managed to complete the
since now longest natural trail
with full accessibility in helsinki and
it goes along a place that is that is
also an important bird area in the very
geographic center of the city where you
can actually spot a spot uh
dozens and dozens of different bird
species and now you can do it with a
which wheelchair
and it's accessible for all really
important in these times
that was also a project where the um
to whom the accolade uh was uh granted
uh by the council on disability
and to conclude i want to thank uh all
the other cities uh who have been
shortlisted and to whose achievements uh
we have been listening uh
we will
certainly want to learn more from you
and be inspired by you during the next
year
and of course most of all i want to
thank everyone at the city of helsinki
who has put their effort their work uh
their will to make helsinki uh a more
accessible city thank you
congratulations again for receiving this
and we're so excited to see your
excitement of receiving this award i'm
sure that you're going to use it to
inspire the staff in helsinki to make
even further efforts so let's have a
little look and we've got a video from
you to see some of the improvements you
made that got you to the second place
access city award 2022 second prize
helsinki finland 653
835 inhabitants
helsinki finland's capital city is by
far the most populous urban area in the
country and the center for the country's
politics education finance culture and
research
its urban area and burgeoning
international and local
present accessibility challenges for the
city having won second place in the
access city awards 2015 the city's
continued dedication and commitment has
now led to an all-encompassing approach
that addresses all kinds of
accessibility issues
approved in 2005 the city's
accessibility plan commits its offices
and institutions to developing
accessible public facilities and
services
several actions have already been
implemented all trams and trains in
helsinki are accessible all metro
stations have at least one lift with
warning markings along the edge of
platforms and new accessible tram stops
have been built with older stops
renovated to meet accessibility
standards
on top of this plan as of 2012 a
permanent accessibility representative
was appointed to coordinate and promote
accessibility work across the city
with an advisory board the aim is to
make helsinki fully accessible through
the construction and renovation of the
city's public spaces buildings and
public transport
the objective is to make them safe and
accessible for all
including those with physical
disabilities learning disabilities and
neurodiversity
as well as for those persons with
disabilities who are older people or
children and families
for its clear commitment impactful
changes and mainstreaming of
accessibility helsinki wins second prize
in the access city award 2022
[Music]
thanks and congratulations again to
helsinki apologies we missed showing you
the video from barcelona which received
the third place so now let's watch why
they were awarded the third place
access city award 2022 third prize
barcelona spain
one million six hundred and sixty six
thousand five hundred and thirty
inhabitants
barcelona spain's second largest city is
well known for its art and architecture
and attracts millions of visitors every
year
however its size makes accessibility a
challenge
despite this barcelona's commitment to
accessibility is evident by its previous
second place win in the 2011 access city
award and continues with good levels of
accessibility over the years
the city has implemented a strong
accessibility plan which began with a
detailed analysis of the accessibility
of its public spaces facilities and
services
based on the results the city then
implemented changes across the city
the city monitors the situation and
reports that 92 percent of the metro
stations now have a lift between the
platform and the street
the entire metro network now has tactile
maps which lead passengers to ticket
machines with audio instructions
accessible turnstiles and platforms
by 2024 barcelona aims for all its
stations to be accessible for wheelchair
users bathing support systems are now in
place at the four of its beaches
screen readers hearing loops and
accessible documents such as audio books
easy to read and brielle are now present
at most public facilities and services
such as information points health
services theaters and festivals
public libraries are now equipped with
rooms with adapted material for persons
with disabilities and tactile models
accessible maps and adapted guided
visits are available at most museums
for its long-standing approach towards
universal design and accessibility
implementation barcelona wins third
prize in the access city award 2022
[Music]
[Applause]
so those two videos have shown us just
how extensively barcelona and helsinki
have taken not just the legal
responsibility to make all of their
services as spaces accessible but
they've gone well beyond that they've
integrated it into the heart of their
thinking and their mindset
we've still got one more place to
announce
that's the first prize and i'm delighted
to welcome back the commissioner mrs
dally to announce the winner of the
first prize commissioner
before officially announcing the winner
i congratulate all finalists you are all
examples to follow
we need cities like yours to build a
barrier-free europe
the winner of the access city award 2022
has applied in previous years
since the first edition in 2010
and every year they have done more
they received a special mention in a
previous edition
and won a third prize
today they win the most prestigious
european prize on accessibility that a
city can receive
the winner of the access city award
2022
is
luxembourg city congratulations
[Applause]
okay now
we don't know what happened why did we
receive this price so
the other five also deserved the the
price so um
thank you thank you very much
i prepared a few words in french so
excuse me if it's in french but you
certainly all understand a little bit so
thank you
very much
for the support that we have received
from the european commission who through
the access city award
links up different european cities
this allows us to better advance
together
one of our mottos is a city for all
and this is why
luxembourg city and i have the great
chance of being deputy mayor and
focusing on the inclusion and mobility
of our citizens
and this is where inclusion is
incredibly important
in luxembourg we have a population of
125 000 people
165 nationalities
and more than 70 percent
of people
uh living in luxembourg city don't have
a luxembourgish passport so it's a very
international city
integration as well as inclusion have
always been one of the main priorities
for luxembourg city
it is in this regard
that for a long time that a long time
ago now we adopted the concept of design
for all
which
when it comes to urban planning
uh includes inclusive mobility in the
design of roads
and amenities and infrastructure to
render them more accessible
so that all city services can
be urbanized and serve everyone
inclusion is one of the bedrocks of our
urban planning but this approach isn't
only for new projects we also adapt all
our existing infrastructure
often as a respond to a specific
need
to make people's itineraries
safer
and we make
pavements
and road crossings safer for our
citizens
this
challenge has been to make our city more
accessible and we have made a lot of
progress in this regard in offering a
more public transport
as you all
know and for those of you who maybe
don't for more than a year now all
public transport is free for everyone in
luxembourg
this has considerably increased the use
of public transport
so the fact that the bus is free
the fact that we have accessible trams
all of this has favored uh development
digital information panels and signs
and
tramways offer
live
information
which facilitates transport between
cities and a lot of
public transport
um stops
use eb cons e beacons
that are equipped with bluetooth to help
people
who are visually impaired
they can receive
instant messages when they approach a
bus stop
they can receive um live information and
other practical information to make
their journey
safer and simpler
we wanted to guarantee accessibility to
our population and this also
meant that we had to
have this in three different languages
french german and english in order to
make sure that we could have an
inclusive city and a design for all
we needed
a
an integrative infrastructure that could
include all these different
projects
raise awareness about
our transport and listen to our citizens
with specific needs
building an inclusive
city takes a lot of time and commitment
it requires teamwork and the inclusion
of active participation of stakeholders
who know the specific needs
the best
so in this regard i would like to thank
all of the various different services as
well as madeline kaiser
she was incredibly helpful and all
other city services as well as our
partners who throughout the year
throughout these last few years have
been
working
with us
they have been by our side on a daily
basis to make our city more accessible
so thank you very much for giving us
this prize we are not going to stop our
efforts there we're going to continue
our work and continue exchanging with
other cities
thank you very much and congratulations
to the other cities who weren't
nominated
and commissioner you said that
luxembourg have submitted an application
every single year and they committed
having just won the top prize to go even
further isn't that encouraging to see
yes and we would like to see more of
this of course in other cities let's
watch a little video to see exactly what
luxembourg did this year to get the top
prize
access city award 2022 first prize
luxembourg city luxembourg 124
528 inhabitants
built upon a rock the city of
luxembourg's distinctive terrain and
narrow streets make it a historical and
unique place to live
however its picturesque terrain and
location have made accessibility a
challenge
despite this the city continues to
prioritize accessibility since its
access city awards special mention in
2015 and third place win in 2018
year after year it delivers more
innovative solutions and improvements
thanks to the city's design for all and
participatory approach the overall
accessibility has gone from strength to
strength
low floor buses equipped with ramps are
present across the city as well as
visual and audio announcements on buses
and at bus stops
the real service of luxembourg is
accessible to everyone and free to use
since march twenty twenty
train stations throughout the city offer
accessible toilets accessible parking
spaces and have signage using pictograms
many displays have a text-to-speech
function
to ensure the design for all approaches
met the city regularly consults its
citizens and particularly those with
disabilities through participatory
committees reflection days and awareness
raising weeks
this has also resulted in key city
council meetings being made available in
sign language on top of spoken language
and accessible transcription
to ensure that political decisions are
accessible for everyone
for its transversal approach to
accessibility luxembourg city wins first
prize in the access city award 2022.
[Music]
congratulations again luxembourg for
achieving the top prize this year what
fantastic work you've done
what a wonderful afternoon
we've enjoyed learning about the
creative ways that city leaders have
prioritized accessibility for their
citizens especially those with
disabilities by striving for equality
cities have implemented changes and
removed barriers that have direct impact
on the lives of citizens and visitors
with disabilities
we've heard testimonies from individuals
of how their experiences have been
transformed through deliberate and
thoughtful redesign of infrastructure
services and environments
today's prize winners have demonstrated
that efforts invested in accessibility
bring rewards not only for persons with
disabilities but for everyone releasing
their talents and allowing them to
contribute to a vibrant thriving city
we hope you've been inspired by what you
saw today and the today's ceremony marks
the start of many other journeys towards
accessible cities
maybe next year your city can also be
recognized for the progress that it has
been made
thank you and goodbye from brussels
[Music]
[Music]
you